what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the boys right we're
finally back on track with the boys dear
becky one thing i do want to specify you
guys were right about billy butcher and
compound v i'm not sure why i thought he
hadn't taken it yet it wasn't really
confusing with the comics of the tv show
but i had to go back and read the boys
issue number 50 and that's when it's
established that he had compound v
before like huey came along and back
when he was with mallory so you were
correct that's my mistake as always i do
get stuff wrong sometimes for some
reason that i'll never fully understand
people are always under the assumption
that i never get things wrong that's not
true i am a human being
i do get things wrong sometimes and it's
ridiculous to believe that i don't but
the thing about this is in the last
video that we covered you basically had
vicar right he was kind of like the boys
version of thor and that where billy
butcher had basically interrogated vicar
and wanted to use him as what was
essentially an inside man that in turn
vicar had kind of ambushed billy butcher
with the intention of taking billy
butcher out using the vicar family right
so like the asgardians by all standards
of measurement is really what these guys
are kind of like the warriors three to a
degree maybe a bit of hercules thrown in
there but the thing about this and
what's really awesome about this moment
is that when this whole thing goes down
billy butcher's like okay so like this
is your idea is to basically take me out
bringing your whole family in okay
here's the cool thing though did you
really think i'd show up here with no
real backup whatsoever and that's when
the female comes in now one of the
things that i saw going through the
comments for the last video is that
people seemed a little bit confused
about when this takes place i imagine it
might be just because you sort of joined
in late one of the things that we
established an issue number in the
really the first video that we did with
issue number one is that dear becky it
was released after the boys this segment
that we're covering here with billy
butcher takes place before the main boys
comic so it's basically a prelude to the
original boys comic book run so that's
why i've kind of left out the stuff with
huey because pretty quickly i came to
the realization that if i hadn't done
that it would have been really confusing
to jump back before jump back and forth
between the past and the present plus
what's going on with huey doesn't really
matter all that much this is definitely
the more interesting part of the story
so that's one of the things that i want
to want you guys to specify is this all
takes place before the main story of the
boys back when billy butcher was working
for mallory now the other part of this
is of course we also have the female
that shows up here and just based on a
little bit of confusion that we had i
might just sort of be retreading water
here but i do want to offer this a
little bit of an explanation the female
as she exists in the comics is very
different from the version of the
character that you see in the show she
like the development you saw for her in
the show you get virtually none of that
in the comic in the comic she's just
kind of like just this animalistic
almost type character that's really just
kind of like the the heavy hitter to a
degree of billy butcher right like
whenever he wants to get something done
and he wants to use violence as the
all-encompassing answer to most all of
life's problems uh that in turn he
basically sends in the female to handle
it form and that's exactly what happens
here that the female's ferocity as it
exists here which you saw a little bit
of in the show but it's all it's a lot
more intense in the comic than it is in
the show like when she freaked out and
she basically like she killed that guy
and like all of his henchmen and had
like the the hookers and stuff there
that's her pretty much the entire time
in the comic right that's basically her
like for the most part in the comic
which is why it was so cool to see it in
the show but she literally goes through
here and just starts tearing apart the
entire family and literally billy
butcher's just making vicar watch it
right these folks are just like
screaming and begging for their lives
and billy's just kind of like i mean
look man just one thing to keep in mind
you kind of brought this on yourself
right i mean we could have done this
easy right we could have done this in a
pretty easy and straightforward way but
you wanted to play hardball you want to
try to force my hand you wanted a strong
army so i had to sort of help you
understand your place in the bigger
picture have no illusions here you are
doing this because your life depends on
it we've literally dismantled your
entire family some we've killed and some
we haven't but one thing i want you to
be aware of is that we can kill you at
any point in time at any moment we can
kill you right so just be aware of that
if you decide to do something foolish
like this again and so in the end he
sends him back in and says like your job
is to get us the information that we
need if you decide not to this will be
you laying in pieces around here right
that's kind of the crazy thing now one
of the cool moments that we kind of jump
back and forth with because one of the
great things about about dear becky is
it focuses a lot on the relationship
between billy butcher and his wife right
between him and becky and so you have
this really cool conversation here where
it kind of picks up in the middle of
them talking and she says by the way i
said we'd meet guy and sheila for a
curry tomorrow night which i don't know
why anybody would ever say no to that
curry is amazing
all right and there's a little bit of
banter back and forth regarding whether
or not you know billy likes her and you
know kind of like i'm not really feeling
her and you know she's your friend
that's really the reason why i'm going
and that kind of a thing but it's one of
those things where the conversation kind
of transitions into the bigger talk and
she sees these kids who are playing over
there and she says you know i think
those kids might want their swings back
and billy's of course like you know well
you know we'll give them a tube of glue
to play with you know they'll be fine
they're kids but the discussion kind of
starts going in this direction of the
two of them talking when she tries to
sort of get billy butcher to open up a
little bit and they start talking about
a guy named freddy caldwell right who
was basically the person that billy
seemed to kind of confide in and he says
you know like i'm happy you know
honestly i couldn't be happier right i'm
off the booze my mom's away from my dad
you know and in the end the response of
becky is i know all of that but it's
like i was saying all that stuff that
you've seen and done over those years it
doesn't just go away and the
responsibility is like look i'm not
saying i forgot all of it or nothing or
anything like that but it doesn't bother
me i just shut it away and that's a very
important plot point for the character
of billy and the reason why is because
becky says the only people who really do
just compartmentalize that part of
themselves it goes away it's never dealt
with and it has no impact on their on
their lives in that capacity are people
who are crazy and she's like you're not
that kind of person right you'd be cold
you'd be ruthless you'd be empty and
that'd be all there was to you all the
good stuff between us would basically
just be an act in this world that we
live in right and it's kind of
antiquated terms to use here but you
have
psychopaths and sociopaths now the more
common term to use is somebody who just
has anti-social personality disorder and
the reason why is because there are some
some aspects of sociopathy and
psychopathy and like narcissism and
things like that that just sort of blend
together and in some circumstances it's
actually very difficult to differentiate
between any of those those personality
disorders right borderline personality
disorder different things like that and
so it's much easier to sort of attribute
it to a general anti-social personality
disorder and focus more on the different
uh traits they have as opposed to trying
to compartmentalize them into being a
psychopath or a sociopath or having
borderline personality disorder or
bipolar personality disorder or
something along those lines you know
narcissism or what have you but the
reality here is that a lot of those
personality traits include things like
lacking empathy whether or not a person
was born without empathy in the case of
what we would traditionally call a
psychopath or a person lost their
ability to be empathetic which is what
you would consider to be a sociopath is
the fact that they simply just don't
have it and that's really what becky's
talking about here is this idea that if
billy butcher really truly is that kind
of person where he really has shut off
that part of himself then in reality the
pain that he would feel from the things
that he would experience would be a
reflection of the fact that he does feel
empathy he does feel emotions and
sadness and different things along those
lines by compartmentalizing it shutting
it off and putting it away he literally
gets rid of the part of him that's human
hence the statement he would be cold he
would be ruthless and he would be empty
there'd be no warmth to him that all
these conversations that she and and he
have the intimate moments right when
they're sleeping together right when
they're making love or when they're
watching a show together or having a
funny little moment it would all just be
pretend it would be him going through
the motions because it's him just
appearing to be normal but in reality he
lacks anything that makes him a warm and
comforting human being in all honesty
she doesn't want to believe that and so
what's interesting is she says they say
the one thing that really helps if you
suffer trauma is talking about it right
to people who've been through the same
sort of thing and i've looked into this
there's these groups of veterans some
from the falklands some from northern
ireland or wherever and in the end they
have these conversations and they talk
about it and the reason why that helps
people get through these individual
traumas is because it reminds them that
they're not alone that people who
struggle with a lot of those personality
disorders create a kind of safe space
around themselves right they literally
box themselves in they create an
isolating circumstance and what that
does is it creates a feeling of being
alone and as time progresses they come
to see themselves as being alone no one
else out there can relate to them
because no one else has been what
they've been through but they believe
that because they've never talked to
anybody else who's been what they've
been through but billy butcher is not
the first person to lose someone who was
close to him he's not the first person
to experience abuse he's not the first
person to have these these terrible
circumstances plague his life and by
talking to other people who have been
through the same thing he has that in
turn it would grant him a sense of
connection that he simply just doesn't
have but the reality is that billy
butcher just kind of writes it off and
what's most interesting about this is
becky lets him feelings emotions that's
that's girl stuff right girls feel girls
love and and they hate and they
experience sadness and happiness right
like you know guys don't experience that
kind of stuff but what's so interesting
about the character of billy butcher is
that if you look at his character in the
boys you look at him even kind of now in
this present following dear becky or
following the death of becky he is that
guy he's the guy that becky described
cold ruthless that kind of a thing and
what so what's really interesting about
this and it's really kind of garth and
it's asking us the question is that the
kind of person billy butcher always was
or is that the kind of person billy
butcher became because becky was the
only thing anchoring him to something
meaningful in his life it was was her
death just this straw that broke the
camel's back the one level of pain that
he couldn't endure anymore then he just
shut that part of himself off to the
world and it's by any means necessary
right that's the question that's asked
here that's what's so interesting
because you get this really great
conversation between him and becky and
then garth ennis immediately juxtaposes
it to a point where he's in the elevator
and he's talking to these people and
they're like man like how are you
allowed allowed to have a dog in here
like i didn't know you were allowed to
have a dog in here like this soup is
just like the super is a dick about it
like any time we ever had to try have
some kind of a conversation like
literally it was no like there's no way
you're having any kind of an animal in
here and so in the end like billy's like
i mean she's all right you know and
they're like not to us she wasn't like
she was terrible to us like how did you
manage to get a pet in here and the
responsibility is well the fact of the
matter is that they're the bloku had
this place before you he was a bit of a
girl right like he was a nasty guy right
he was a junkie he kept the place like a
freaking sty right he got behind on the
rent and i mean we're talking about like
months and months behind so she went
around to ask him about it and he just
went over the top and lost his mind on
her so he told her that he was like hiv
positive and if she didn't like piss off
that he'd cut himself and spray it all
over which is a pretty extreme thing to
do and like she tried to have him
evicted and an attorney said if you do
like i'll come back later and i'll kill
you and so in the end billy's like i
basically threw him at his kitchen
window and i broke his back and after
that
tara has been allowed to stay here as
often as he wants to right like violence
is not always the answer but it is a
answer and it's usually a very effective
one and so that's the the crazy
circumstance here is because following
that you know it's really kind of this
extreme juxtaposition right like the
billy butcher who's with becky and seems
warm laughing and while he is a bit of a
hard ass you can tell there's a soft
interior there and that really becky
seems to be the only one who gets to
experience that then you get this hard
ass billy butcher right so it's really
interesting to see these kind of
juxtapositions there but beyond that we
basically end up switching back to kind
of the main story here right where you
have billy butcher talking with mother's
milk and talking with uh with frenchie
and having this interesting conversation
where they're talking about how billy
butcher basically sees mallory because
one of the things to keep in mind is the
underlying theme here is that mallory
does things by the book and that billy
butcher believes that like it's time to
really start like hitting superheroes
hard right even killing them if they
have to but mallory doesn't want to do
that maui's more about containing and
controlling superheroes basically being
the kind of authority that they need
that they're not getting from vaude
american right if vaude american and the
boys are the mom and dad of superheroes
then like the boys are the ones who
basically punish them and vaude
americans are the ones that let them get
away with whatever they want to that's
kind of how this whole this whole
dichotomy works under mallory right
under under mallory as the leader of the
boys billy butcher's response is no we
have to hit them harder we have to make
them afraid of breaking the rules we
can't give them a slap on the wrist
because eventually a time's going to
come when they're not going to be afraid
of what we can do they're going to be
like then do something what do i need to
worry about but what's the worst i have
to worry about from you right you're
like yeah i don't have to worry about
anything from you like it's a slap on
the wrist and that's it right they start
calling bluffs and then suddenly when
they realize that malory does not have
an ace up the sleeve the boys are
toothless the responsibility butcher is
we have to be willing to go all the way
right we cannot be high road defeatists
we can't be the ones who are like i
would rather maintain my morals and lose
than do whatever it takes to win right
because once you come across a person
who will do whatever it takes to win
your defeat's been guaranteed right like
you are guaranteed to lose because you
won't go to the same level they are and
so it's a really interesting thing
because in this conversation between
them that's when he really kind of
starts showing it off to really kind of
showing frenchie and mother's milk that
he thinks he'd actually be a more
capable leader than mallory he doesn't
say it so much but that's the subtlety
that's the undercurrent that's the kind
of subversive message that's being
delivered to them and so when malory
arrives on the scene the question that
really goes down here is what do they do
about the scorchers because remember the
scorchers is a team that's out there and
they're the one that's basically being
created by julian baxter puke now
remember julian baxter pugh is this guy
who was brought in and he's really head
of like media corps right kind of like
the television film arms so to speak of
vod american but when it comes to the
different superheroes with compound v
that vaught deals with it's super human
development that deals with those what
julian baxter puke is doing is he's
basically trying to create a team so we
can execute his own campaign but he's
forcing the hand of vaught by
immediately making this team public and
by immediately making this team public
now they're out there in the world and
they're drawing so much attention that
vaude american can't just kill them off
because julian baxter puke is in a
position to where he can actually expose
what it is that bought americans doing
so to a degree he's kind of blackmailing
them and really just kind of forcing
their hand here there's absolutely
nothing that superhuman development can
really do about this and so that's when
mallory says this new team is well and
truly launched and superhuman
development can't do a damn thing about
it it would obviously be in our interest
to make sure that this mission of julian
baxter pugh goes off without a hitch and
that's when the question of billy is
like do we really want another superhero
superhero team running around out there
and in the end the response of mallory
is we want to stir the pot the greater
vaught americans internal problems the
easier our job is because while they're
focusing on internal strife they're not
focusing on us and if they're not
focusing on us we can start to get in
right like that door might be left
cracked and if that door is accidentally
left cracked that's our way in and it's
accidentally left open because they're
not paying attention right this is the
kind of thing that we need it's one of
those things where he says it's the
theory of corporate competition yielding
the best results these people probably
make their kids fight over presents on
christmas morning if butcher's right
this'll happen sooner rather than later
mother's milk as soon as the bugs yield
anything i want to know about it
understood because remember they have
the whole place bugged where the
scorchers reside and all that kind of
stuff a lot of the conversations they've
heard have just kind of been them
arguing and bickering over the nature of
the team or whether or not they're gonna
finally make it to the seven what their
purpose is that kind of stuff nothing
hugely significant here right a little
bit of information but if anything it
just kind of gives them the structure of
the team but nothing they can incredibly
use to force the hand of the team or
force a team to work for them in some
capacity but what happens is we get this
sort of uh kind of letter because
remember the whole idea of dear becky is
billy butcher writing a journal to
essentially becky herself and he says
like you've been gone for years becky
why is it that you're on my mind so much
i've been cracking skulls from malory
all this time i've even slipped the odd
throat i get what i want and he gets
what he wants and one day i'll even get
a go at the bastard i'm really after of
course being homeland he says i think
it's because you know what i know and he
says and what i know or what i come to
understand is cracking skulls is not
enough anymore neither is the odd throat
not when it comes to the superheroes and
so what's really going on here is billy
butcher is essentially mentally at the
very least preparing to make his moves
as far as he's concerned mallory is a
half measure he's not willing to do what
it takes to actually win he's a high
road defeatist billy butcher's stance is
we have to basically be willing to go
all the way because if we're not willing
to go all the way they're going to
figure that out and when they figure
that out it's done so game over right
whether they kill us or not we have no
teeth we have no recourse they have no
reason to be afraid of us so in effect
mentally at the very least he's
preparing things for when the actual
boy's comic comes along he's running the
team and he basically is willing to pull
out all the stops and do whatever it
takes to come out on top but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace